let's start guys okay so we're gonna
continue talking about games today and
just quick announcement the project
proposals are due today I think you all
know that all right so let's good
tomorrow right okay yeah today is not
Thursday yeah tomorrow for a second I
thought it's Thursday all right so let's
talk about games so we started talking
about games last time we formalized them
we talked about none we talked about
zero-sum two-player games that were
turn-taking
right and we talked about a bunch of
different strategies to solve them like
the minimax strategy or the expecting
max strategy and today we want to talk a
little bit about learning in the setting
of games so what does learning mean how
do we learn those evaluation functions
that we talked about and then towards
the end of the lecture we want to talk a
little bit about variations of the game
the games you have talked about so how
about you have how about the cases where
we have simultaneous games or
nonzero-sum games so that's a that's a
plan for today so I'm gonna start with a
question that you're actually going to
talk about it towards the end of the
lecture but it's a good motivation so
think about a setting where we have a
simultaneous two player zero-sum game so
it's a two player zero-sum game similar
to the games we talked about last time
but it is simultaneous so you're not
taking turns you're playing at the same
time and an example of that is
rock-paper-scissors so can you still be
optimal if you reveal your strategy
so we'll say you're playing with someone
if you tell them what your strategy is
can you still be optimal that's the
question exactly what you're going to
play you won't be successful too huge
for a zero-sum real-time so I was using
a larger scale I think you could still
be successful if that approach is like
superior to the others rates
so it's not so the answer was about the
size of the game so rock-paper-scissors
being small versus versus not being
small so so the question is more of a
motivating thing people talk about this
a lot of details towards the end of the
class it's actually not the size that
matters is a type of strategy that you
play that matters just to give you an
idea but like the reason that we have
put this I guess at the beginning of the
lecture is intuitively when you think
about this you might say no I'm not
gonna tell you what my strategy is right
because if I say I'm gonna play like
scissors you'll know what to play but
this has an intuitive answer that you're
gonna talk about towards the end of the
lecture so just more of a motivating
example don't think about it too hard
all right so so let's do a quick review
of games so so last night we talked
about having an agent an opponent
playing against each other so and you
were playing for the agent and the agent
was trying to maximize their utility so
they were trying to get this utility the
example we looked at was agent is going
to pickpocket a bucket B or bucket C and
then the opponent is going to pick a
number from these buckets they can
either pick minus 50 or 51 or 3 or minus
5 or 15 and then if you want to maximize
your your utility as an agent then you
can potentially think that your opponent
is trying to trying to minimize your
utility and you can have this minimax
game kind of playing against each other
and based on that decide what to do so
we had this minimax tree and based on
that the utilities that are gonna pop up
or minus 51 and minus 5 so if your goal
is to maximize your utility you're gonna
pick bucket be the second bucket because
that's the best thing you can do
assuming your opponent is a minimizer so
so that was kind of the setup that we
started looking at and the way we
thought about solving this game why was
by writing a recurrence so so we had
this value this is V which was the value
of a minimax at state s and if you're at
the utility so if you're at an end state
you're gonna get utility of s right like
if you get to the end state we get the
utility because we get the utility only
idea at the very end of the game and if
the agent is playing we the recurrence
is maximize V of the successor States
and if the opponent is playing
want to minimize the value of the
successor States so that was the
recurrence we started with and and we
looked at games that were kind of large
like the game of chess and if you think
about the game of chess the branching
factor is huge the depth is really large
it's not practical to you to do the
recurrence so we we started talking
about waste for speeding things up and
one way to speed things up with this
idea of using an evaluation function so
do their recurrence but only do it until
some depth so don't go over the full
tree just do it until some depth and
then after that just call an evaluation
function and hopefully your evaluation
function which is kind of this weak
estimate of your value is going to work
well and give you an idea what to do
next so so instead of the usual
recurrence what we did was we decided to
add this knee here and this D right here
which is the depths that until which we
are exploring and then we decrease the
value of depth after an agent an
opponent place and then my depth is
equal to zero we just call an evaluation
function so intuitively if you're
playing chess for example you might
think a few steps ahead and when you
think a few steps ahead you might think
about how the board looks like and kind
of evaluates that based on the features
that that that board has and based on
that you might you might decide to take
various actions so similar type of idea
and then the question was well how are
we going to come up with a solution
function like where is this evaluation
function coming from and then one idea
that that we talked about last time was
it can be handcrafted the designer can
come in and sit down and figure out what
is a good evaluation function so in the
game of chase and test example is you
have this evaluation function that can
depend on the number of pieces you have
the mobility of your pieces maybe the
safety of your king central control all
these various things that you might care
about so the difference between the
number of Queens that you have and your
opponent's number of Queens these are
things these are features that you care
about and and potentially a designer can
come in and say well I care about nine
times more than I care about how many
pawns I sew so a hand like you can
actually hand design these things and
write down these weights about how much
you care about this so I'm using
terminology from the learning lecture
right I'm saying we have
wait here and we have features here and
someone can comment just handcraft well
one other thing we can do is instead of
hand crafting it we could actually try
to learn this evaluation function so so
we can still have to have two features
right we can still say well I care about
the number of kings and queens and these
are things that I have but I don't know
how much I care about them and I
actually want to learn that evaluation
function like what the weights should be
so to do that I can write my evaluation
function eval of s as this me as a
function of state parameterize by pie
weights doubles and and my goal is to
figure out what these w's what these
weights are and ideally I want to learn
that from some data ok so so we're going
to talk about how learning is applied to
the game setting and specifically the
way we are using learning for these game
settings is to just get a better sense
of what this evaluation function should
be from some data so so the questions
you might have right now is well how
does we look like where does my data
come from because I find if you know
where your data comes from and your V is
then all you need to do is to come up
with a learning algorithm that takes
your data and tries to figure out what
your V is so so we're going to talk
about that at the first part of
knowledge and that kind of introduces to
this this temporal difference learning
which you're gonna discuss in a second
it's very similar to key learning and
then towards the end of the class we'll
talk about simultaneous games and
nonzero symbols
all right so so let's start with this V
function I just said well this new
function could be parameterize by a set
of weights I set up double use and the
simplest form of this V function is to
just write it as a linear classifier as
as a linear function of a set of
features double use time space and these
these are the features that are hind
coded and someone writes them and then
and then I just want to figure out what
W sir so this is the simplest form but
in general did this this V function
doesn't need to be a linear classifier
it can actually be any supervised
learning model that you have discussed
in the first few lectures it can be a
neural network it can be anything even
more complicated than network that just
does regression so we can basically any
model you could use in supervised
learning could be placed here
as I see function so all I'm doing is
I'm writing this P function as a
function of state and a bunch of
parameters those parameters in the case
of linear classifiers are just w's and
in the case of the neural network there
are WS and these fees in this case of
like one layer alright so let's look at
an example so let's think about an
example and I'm gonna focus on the
linear classifier way of looking at this
just for simplicity so okay let's pick a
game so we're gonna look at backgammon
so this is a very old game it's a
two-player game the way it works is you
have the red player and you have the
white player and each one of them have
these pieces and what they want to do is
they want to move all their pieces from
one side of the board to the other side
of the board it's a game of chance you
can actually like roll two dice and
based on the outcome of your dice you
move your pieces various various amounts
to two various columns there bunch of
rules so your goal is to get all your
pieces off the board but if you have
only like one piece and your opponent
like gets on top of you they can push
you to the bar and you have to like
start again there are a bunch of rules
about it read about it on Wikipedia if
you're interested but you're gonna look
at a simplified version of it so in this
simplified version I have player O and
play your X and I only have four columns
I have column 0 1 2 & 3 and in this case
I have four of each one of these players
and and the idea is we want to come up
with features that we would care about
in this game of backgammon so so what
are some features how do you think might
be useful
remember the learning lecture how do we
come up with like future templates third
is still down with the color but it's a
mistake so maybe like the location of
the X's and O's the number of them yeah
yeah so like what idea is you have all
these knowledge about the boards so
maybe we should like care about the
location of the X's maybe we should care
about like where the O's are how many
pieces are on the board how many pieces
are off the board so similar type of way
that we would come up with features in
the first few lectures we were basically
we would do the same thing so a feature
template set of feature templates could
look like this like number of
X's or OS in column whatever con being
equal to some value or a number of
excess zeros on the bar may be fraction
of excesses or OS that are removed whose
turn it is so these are all like
potential features that it could be so
for this particular board here are what
those features would look like so if you
look at number of OS in column 0 equal
to 1 that's equal to 1 remember we were
using these indicator functions to be
more general so like here again we are
using this indicator functions you might
ask number of O's on a bar that's equal
to one fraction of O's that are removed
so I have four pieces two of them are
already removed so that's one half
number of X's in column one equal to 1
that's one number of X's and columns
three equal to three that's one it's to
stern so that's a cool okay so so we
have a bunch of features these features
kind of explain what the sport looks
like or how good this world is and what
we want to do is we want to figure out
what it what are the weights that we
should put for each one of these
features and how much we should care
about each one of these features so that
is the goal of learning here okay all
right so okay so that was my model right
so far I've talked about this vs of W I
defined it as a linear classifier
predictor W times features and now the
question is where do I get data like
where it's because if I'm doing learning
I got to get data from somewhere so so
what idea that we can use here is we can
try to generate data based on our
current policy PI agent or PI opponent
which is based on our current estimate
of what we use right so currently I
might have some idea of what this V
function is it might be a very bad idea
of what V is but that's okay I can just
start with that and starting with that V
function that I currently have what I
can do is I can I can call our max of V
over successors of SN a to get a policy
for my agent
remember this was how we were getting
policy in a minimax setting policy for
the opponent is just argument of that V
function and then when I call these
policies I get a bunch of actions I get
a sequence of like states based on based
on how we're following these policies
and that is some data that I can
actually go over and try to make might
be better and better so so that's kind
of how we do it we call these policies
we get
bunch of episodes we go over them to
make things better and better so that's
kind of the key idea um one question you
might have at this point is is this
deterministic or not like do I need to
do something like Epsilon greedy so in
general you would need to do something
like epsilon greedy but in this
particular case you don't really need to
do that because we have again it like we
have this guy that you're actually
rolling the dice and by rolling the dice
you are getting random different
different random paths that that we
might take so that would take us
different states so we kind of already
have this this element of random this
year that does some of the exploration
for us you just like yes so why if
someone greedy what I mean here is do I
need to do extra exploration am I gonna
get stuck like in particular set of
states if I don't do exploration and in
this particular case because we have
this randomness we don't really need to
do that in general you might imagine
having some sort of epsilon greedy to
take us explore a little bit more okay
so then we generate episodes and then
from these episodes we want to learn
okay his episodes look like state action
reward states and then they keep going
until like if you get a full episode one
thing to notice here is is the reward is
going to be 0
throughout the episode until the very
end of end of the game right like on
till we end the episode and we might get
some reward at that point or we might
not but but the reward throughout is
going to be equal to 0 because we were
playing a game right like you're not
getting any rewards available and if you
think about each one of these small
pieces of experience si RS prime you can
try to learn something from each one of
these pieces of experience okay so so
what you have is actually going bored
maybe what you have here is you have a
piece of experience it's not like s hey
you get some reward maybe it is zero
that's fine if it is zero and you go to
some s 5 through that so let's take an
action and you get a reward and you get
a reward you go to something from that
and you have some prediction right your
prediction is your current like your
current V function so your predict
is going to be this V function at the
state s prime meter eyes with W and this
is what your already like you kind of
know right now this is your current
estimate or what he is and this is your
prediction I'm writing the prediction as
a function of W right because it depends
on W and then we had a target that your
try to get to and my target which is
kind of acts as a label it's going to be
equal to my reward the reward that I'm
getting so it's kind of the route so if
you look at this V of s and W well
what's kind of Polish to reward plus I'm
gonna write discount factor yeah del V
of s prime right so so my target the
thing that I'm trying to like get to is
the reward plus gamma V of s prime so
we're playing games in games gamma is
usually one I'm gonna keep it here for
now but I'm gonna drop it at some point
so you don't need to really worry about
gamma and then one other thing to notice
here is I'm not writing target as a
function of W because target acts kind
of like my label right if I'm if I'm
trying to do regression here how get is
my label it's kind of the ground truth
thing that I'm trying to get to so I'm
gonna treat my target
that's just like a value I'm not writing
it as function of W all right so so what
do we try to do usually like when you're
trying to do learning yeah a prediction
we have a target what do I do
minimize say yeah so what is there so I
can write my error as potential you
squirt or so I'm gonna write 1/2 of
prediction of W minus target squirt this
is my square there I want to minimize
that so with respect to W okay how do I
do that I can take the gradient what is
a gradient equal to this is simple right
so you do two gets cancelled gradient is
just this guy prediction of
w- target times the gradient of this
inner expression the gradient of this
inner expression with respect to w is
the gradient of prediction with respect
to w minus zero plus target is treating
it as a number okay let me move this up
so now I have the gradient what
algorithm should I use I can use
gradient descent right so I'm going to
update my W how do I update it I'm going
to move in the negative direction of my
gradient using some learning rate a de
times my gradient my gradient is
prediction of W minus target times
gradient of prediction of W all right so
that's actually what's on the slide so
the objective function there's
prediction - target squared
gradient we just took that it's
prediction - target times gradient of
prediction and then the update is just
this this particular update probably
move in a negative direction of the
gradient this is this is what you guys
have seen already all right so so far so
good
um so this is the TD learning algorithm
this is all it does so temporal
difference learning what it does is it
picks like these pieces of experience
si R s prime and then based on that
pieces of experience it just updates W
based on this gradient descent update
difference between prediction and target
times a gradient of V so what happens if
I have if I have this this linear
function may be let me write let me
write this in the case that I have a
linear linear function so what if my V
of s W is just equal to W dot feel this
LS so what happens to my update - ADA
what is prediction right
although you don't feel this little horn
what is target did you find it up there
it's the reward you're getting the
immediate reward you're getting plus
gamma times V of s prime W which is w
dot V of s prime times gradient of your
prediction which is what's the illness
so I just I just wrote up this in the
case of a linear predictor case what you
learn you know where the difference is
between you two yeah so this is very
similar to Q learning they're very minor
differences that you'll talk about
actually at the end of this section
comparing it to Q line all right so so I
want to go over an example it's kind of
like a tedious example but I think it
helps going over that and kind of saying
why it works especially in the case that
the reward is just equal to zero like
throughout an episode so it kind of
feels funny to use this algorithm and
make it work but it works so I want to
just go over like one example of this so
I'm gonna show you one episode starting
from s 1 to some other state and and I
have an episode I start from some state
I get some features of that state again
these features are by just evaluating
those hand-coded features and I'm just
gonna start what W should I start with 0
let me just initialized over u to be
equal to 0 ok right how do I update my W
maybe let me just write it in this so so
this is I want to write in as simple or
not the simpler form we're just in the
other form so W the way we're updating
it is previous W - ADA times prediction
- target I'm going to use P and T for
prediction - target times V of s this is
update you are doing ok yeah that's
right okay so so what is my prediction
with my prediction W dot C of s 0 what
is my target so for my target I need to
know what state I'm ending up at I'm
gonna end up at 1 0 in this episode and
I'm gonna get a reward of 0 so what is
my target my target is reward which is 0
plus double
times V of s prime that is zero because
W is equal to zero so my target is equal
to zero my P minus P is equal to zero so
P minus C is equal to zero this whole
thing is 0 W stays the same so in the
next kind of step that we use just okay
I'm gonna move forward so what is
prediction here 0 x 0 prediction is 0
what is target I haven't yeah it's 0
because I haven't got any anything any
word yet about 1/2 so yeah so target is
going to be a reward which is 0 plus 0
times whatever state of V of s prime
that I'm at so that's equal to 0 P minus
C is equal to 0 it's kind of boring so
at this point W haven't changed W is
equal to 0 what is my prediction
prediction is equal to 0 that's great
what is target equal to so I'm gonna end
up in an end state where I get 1 0 and I
get a reward of 1 so this is the first
time I'm getting a reward which is my
target to be my target is reward 1 plus
0 times 1 0 which is 0 so my target is 1
so what this tells me is I'm predicting
0 but my target is 1 so I need to push
my w's a little bit up to actually
address the fact that this is this is
this is equal to 1 so P minus C is equal
to minus 1 so I need to do an update
maybe I'll do that update here so how am
i updating it so I'm doing starting from
zero zero minus my ADA is 0.5 that's
what I allowed it like I put it I
defined it to be my prediction - target
is minus 1 what is fee of s P of s is 1
2 right so what should my new W be for
this an equal to point 5 and then 1 X
I'm just doing arithmetic here
so my new W is going to become 0.5 and 1
at the end of this one episode so I just
did a 1 episode 1 full
we're w0 throughout and then at the very
end when I got a reward then I updated
my W because I realized that my
prediction and target or not the same
thing okay so now I'm gonna I'm gonna
start a new episode and the new episode
I'm starting is going to start with this
particular W and in the new episode even
though the rewards are gonna be 0
throughout so like we're actually going
to update our w's this is amazing think
about the same features right you could
have like I said up yeah depends on what
source or feature you can you could use
like really not representative features
like if you really want S 4 and s 1 s 9
to differentiate between them we should
pick features that differentiates
between them but if you are kind of the
same and have the same sort of
characteristics it's fine to have it's
going to yeah you will never converge
and that kind of tells you that that
entry in your future victory you don't
care about that or it's always like it's
always staying the same and if it is
always zero it doesn't matter like what
the weight of that entry is so in
general we wanna have feature is that or
differentiating and you're losing
something so for the second row I'm not
gonna write it up because that takes
time so so okay so let's start with a
new episode we started this one again
but now I'm starting with this new W
that I have so I can compute the
prediction the prediction is one I can
compute my target it's point five and
what we realize here is we overshoot it
so before prediction was zero target was
one who are under shooting we fixed our
w's but now you're over shooting so we
to fix that variation on the
relationship between the teachers and
elites they always have to be the same
dimension and what should we be thinking
about that would make a good feature for
updating the link specifically like so
okay so first off yes they need to be
always the same there is dimension
because you're doing this dot product
between them the feature selection you
don't necessarily think of it as like
how am i updating the weights you think
of the feature selection as is it
representative of how good my board is
is it for example in the case of
backgammon or is it representative of
how good I'm navigating so so it should
be a representation of how good your
state is and then it's yeah it's usually
like hand designed right so so it's not
necessarily you shouldn't think of it as
how is it helping my weights as you
think of it as how is it representing
how good my state is the blackjack
example you have a threshold of 21 and
then your threshold intent if you're
using the same feature extraction for
both how does that affect the
generalizability of the model the agent
yeah so so you might choose do two
different features and one of them might
be more like so so there is kind of a
trade-off right you might get a feature
that actually the friendships between
different states very well but then that
that makes learning longer that makes it
not as generalizable and then the idea
on the other hand you might get a
feature that's pretty generalizable but
but then it might not do these specific
things that you would want to do or
these differentiating factors about it
so picking features it's an art right so
all right so let me let me move forward
because we have a bunch of things coming
up okay so I'll go over this real quick
then so we have the W's right so so we
now update the W based on this new value
and kind of similar thing you have a
prediction you have a target you're
still over shooting so you still need to
update it and then once you update it to
a point 25 and point 75 and it kind of
stays there you're happy okay all right
so so this was just an example of TD
learning but this is the update that you
have kind of already seen right and then
a lot of you pointed out that this is
this is similar to Q learning already
right this is actually pretty similar
the update is very similar like we have
these gradients and
same way that we have in q-learning and
and we are looking at the difference
between prediction and target same way
that we were looking at in cue learning
but there are some minor differences so
the first difference here is that
q-learning
operates on the cue function q function
is a function over state and actions
here we are operating on a value
function right on V and V is only a
function of state right and part of that
is actually because in the setting and
setting of a game you already know the
rules of the game so we kind of already
know the actions you don't need to worry
about it as much the same way that
you're worrying about it in cue learning
the second difference is Q learning is
an auth policy algorithm so so the
values based on this estimate of the
optimal policy which is this Q opt it's
based on this optimal policy but in the
case of TD learning it's a non policy
the values based on this exploration
policy which is based on a fixed pie and
sure you're updating the PI but you're
going with whatever PI you have and and
kind of running with that I keep
updating it okay so that's another
difference and then finally like in Q
learning you don't need to know the MVP
transitions so you don't need to know
this transition function as transition
from SI to s Prime but in the case of TD
learning you need to know the rules of
the game so you need to know how the
successor function OSN a works so so
those are some kind of minor differences
but from like a perspective of like how
your update works it is pretty similar
to what Q is
all right so so that was kind of this
idea of I have this evaluation function
I want to learn it from data I'm gonna
generate data from that generated data
I'm gonna update my W so that's what
we've been talking about so far and the
idea of learning using learning to play
games is not a new idea actually so so
in 50s
samuel looked at a checkers game program
so where he was using ideas from self
play and ideas from like similar type of
things we have talked about using really
smart features using linear evaluation
functions to try to solve the checkers
program so a bunch of other things that
he did included adding intermediate
rewards so kind of threw out like sui to
get to the end point he added some
intermediate
words use alpha-beta pruning and some
search heuristics and and it was kind of
impressive like what he did in 50's like
he ended up having this game that was
playing like I was reaching like human
em amateur level of play and he only
used like 9k of memory which is like
really impressive if you think about it
so so this idea of learning in games is
old people have been using it in the
case of backgammon this was around 90s
when tesora came up with with an
algorithm to solve the game of
backgammon so he specifically used this
TV Holanda for them which is similar to
the TV learning that we have talked
about it has this lambda temperature
parameter that that kind of tells us how
good states are like as they get far
from the reward he didn't have any any
intermediate rewards usually dumb
features but then he used neural
networks which was kind of cool and he
was able to reach human experts play and
kind of gave us and this kind of gave us
some insights into how to play games and
how to solve like these really difficult
problems and then more recently we have
been looking at the game of growth so in
2016 we had alphago which was using a
lot of expert knowledge in addition to
ideas from Monte Carlo tree search and
then in 2017 yet alphago zero which
wasn't using even expert knowledge it
was all like based on self play it was
using dumb features neural networks and
then basically the main idea was using
Monte Carlo tree search to try to solve
this really challenging difficult
problem so I think in this section
you're gonna talk a little bit about
alphago 0-2 you're attending section all
right so the summary so far is we've
been talking about parameterizing these
evaluation functions using using
features and the idea of TD learning is
to look at this error between our
prediction and our target and try to
minimize that error and find better
double use as we go through so um
alright so that was learning and in
games so now I want to spend a little
bit of time talking about other
variations of games so so the setting
where we take our games two simultaneous
games from turn-based and then the
setting or we go from zero song
nonzero-sum alright okay simultaneous
games so um all right so so far we have
talked about turn-based games like chess
where you play and an X player plays and
you play a next play in place and
minimax key and strategies seem to be
pretty okay but it comes to solving
these time bases but not all games are
turn-based right like an example of it
is rock-paper-scissors you're all
playing at the same time everyone is
playing simultaneously the question is
how do we go about solving a
simultaneous so let's search with a game
that is a simplified version of
rock-paper-scissors this is called a two
finger Mora game so the way it works is
we have two players player a and player
B and each player is going to show
either one finger or two fingers and
then you're playing at the same time and
then the way it works is if both of the
players show one at the same time then
player B gives two dollars to play or a
if both of you show two at the same time
player B gives player a four dollars and
then if you show different numbers like
1 or 2 or 2 or 1 then player a has to
give they'll give 3 dollars to 2 player
B ok does that make sense so can you
guys talk to your neighbors and play the
same
[Music]
all right so what was the outcome how
many of you are in the case or a chose
one Danby chose one oh yeah one ok
Whomper here a chose one we chose to
perfect like four people played so I
chose to be chose one okay - and then -
in - all right so so you can kind of see
like a whole mix of strategies here
happening and this is the game that
you're going to talk about a little bit
and think about what would be a good
strategy to use when you're solving this
this simultaneous game yeah all right so
um all right so let's formalize this
yeah player a and player B you have
these possible actions of showing one or
two and then you're gonna use this this
payoff matrix which is which represents
a utility if a chooses action a and B
chooses action B so so before we had
this this value function right before
the itis value function over over our
state here now we have this value
function that is that is again from the
perspective of a agent a so remember
like before we were thinking about value
of function you were looking at it from
the perspective of the first player the
Maximizer player the agent now I'm
looking at all of these scares from the
perspective of a player so so I'm trying
to like get good things for a yeah and
then this is like a one step game -
right so so like you're just playing and
then you see what you get so so we're
not talking about it repeated games
you're playing you see what happens okay
so so we have this V which is V of a and
B and and this basically represent ace
utility if agent a plays a and if agent
B plays and this is called
and then you can represent this with a
matrix and that's why it's called a
payoff matrix I'm gonna write that
payoff matrix here so payoff matrix a
you me here agent a can show one or can
show two agent B can show one or can
show to right if both of us show one at
the same time agent a gets two dollars
if both of us show two at the same time
agent a gets four dollars otherwise
agent a has to pay so agent a gets minus
three dollars and again the reason I
only like to talk about one way is we
are still in the setting of zero-sum
games so whatever we age in a gets agent
B gets negative of that right so so if
agent a gets foreign dollars agent B is
paying minus four dollars so I'm just
writing one B from perspective of agent
a and this is called the payoff matrix
all right so so now we need to talk
about what does a solution mean in this
setting so so what is a policy in this
setting and then the way we refer to
them in this case are as strategies so
we have pure strategy which is almost
like the same thing as as deterministic
policies so a pure strategy is just a
single action that you decide to take so
you have things like period strategies
your strategies the difference between
pure strategy and an deterministic
policy is if you remember a
deterministic policy again is a function
of States right so so it's a policy as a
function of state it gives you an action
here we have like a one move game right
so it's just that one action and we call
it pure strategy we have also this other
thing that's called mixed strategy which
is equivalent to two stochastic policies
and what a mixed strategy is is is a
probability distribution that tells you
what's the probability of you choosing
so so fewer strategies are just actions
ace and then you can have things that
are called mixed strategies and they are
probabilities of our choosing
actually okay all right
so here is an example so if you say well
I'm gonna show you one I'm going to
always show you one then the if you can
you can write that strategy as a pure
strategy that says I'm
always be probable do you want to show
you one and probably what is zero show
you two so so let's say the first column
is for showing one the second column is
for sure so so this is a pure strategy
that says always I'm going to show you
one if I told you well I always I'm
gonna show you two then I can write that
strategy like this right with
probability 1
I'm always showing you 2 I can also come
up with a mixed strategy mix strategy
with me I'm gonna flip a coin and if I
get 1/2 I'm gonna give you I find if I
get heads I'm gonna show you one if I
get tails I'm gonna show you two and
then you can write that as this and this
is going to be a mixed strategy you
could totally play that to your in the
simultaneous game you could just bring
chance in and be like half the time I'm
gonna show you one half the time I'm
going to show you two based on chance
everyone happy with mixed strategies and
your strategies alright so so how do we
evaluate a value of a game so so
remember in previous lecture and like in
the MVP lecture even we were talking
about evaluating if someone gives me the
policy how do I evaluate how good that
is so the way we are evaluating that is
again by this value function me and we
are gonna write this value function as a
function of PI a and PI B you know I'll
just write that up here or I'm gonna
erase this so I'm gonna say a value of
agent a following PI a and agent be
following PI B what is that equal to
well that is going to be the setting
where PI a chooses action a PI B chooses
action be x value of choice a and B
summing over all possible aims okay so
so let's look at an actual example for
this so so for this particular case of
two-finger more game let's say someone
comes in and says I'm gonna tell you
what PI a is policy of agent a is just
always show one and policy of agent B is
this this mixed strategy which is half
the time show one half the time show
show two and and the question is what is
the value of these two policies how do
we compute that
well I'm gonna use my payoff matrix
right so so 1 times 1 over 2 times the
value that we get 1 which is equal to 2
so it's 1 times 1 1 over 2 times 2 plus
0 times 1 over 2 times 4 plus 1 times 1
over 2 times minus 3 the value that I
get is minus 3 plus 0 times 1 over 2
times minus 3 and well what is that
equal to what is that equal to
there are two zeroes here that's minus 1
over 2 okay so I just computed that the
value of these two policies is going to
be minus 1 over 2 and again this is a
front perspective of agent a and it kind
of makes sense right if agent a tells
you I'm gonna always show you 1 then
probably agent and an agent 2 is
following this mixed strategy agent a is
probably losing an agent a is losing
minus 1 over 2 that opens of a whole set
of new questions and you're not
discussing this class so that introduces
repeated games so you might be
interested in looking at what happens in
repeated games in this class right now
we were just talking about this one step
one play we're playing like zero-sum
game and we're playing like Jose
rock-paper-scissors and you just play
once like you might say oh what happens
if you play you're like 10 times then
you're building some relationship and
weird things can happen and so so that
introduces a whole new class oh all
right so so the value is equal to minus
1 over 2 okay
all right so so that was a game value so
so we just evaluated it right if someone
tells me it's Phi a and PI B I can
evaluate it I can know how good PI a and
PI B is
from the perspective of agent a okay so
what do we want to do like when we saw
we want to try to solve games all we
want to do is from the agent ace
perspective you want to maximize this I
want to get as much money as possible
and its values from my agent a
perspective so I should be trying to
maximize this agent mean you should be
trying to minimize this like thinking
minimax agent B should be making
minimizing this agent a should be
maximizing this yeah that's what we want
to do but the challenge here is we're
playing simultaneously so we can't
really use the minimax tree we can
remember any minimax 3 like in that
setting we had sequential place and then
quick like wait for agent a to play and
then after that play and that would give
us a lot of information here we are
playing simultaneously so what should we
do ok so what should we do so I'm gonna
assume we can play sequential e so
that's what I want to do for now so so
I'm gonna limit myself to pure
strategies so maybe I'll I'll come over
here so right now I'm gonna focus only
on pure strategies I won't just consider
a setting very limited setting and see
what happens and I'm gonna assume oh
what if what if we were to play
sequentially what would happen how bad
would it be if we were to play
sequentially so so we have the setting
where player a place goes first
what do you think we do you think like
if player a goes first is that better
for player a or is that worse for player
i worse for player II ok so that's
probably what's gonna happen find out so
player a was trying to maximize right
this me player B was trying to minimize
right and then each of them have a have
actions of either showing 1 or showing 2
this is player a B I can shoot one or
show one or two right if you do want if
we show one one player a gets what $2 is
that right that's right and otherwise
for your it gets - three dollars if you
have two two player a gets four dollars
so
okay so so now if we have this
sequential sitting if you're playing
minimax then player B's going second
player B is going to take the minimizer
here so player B is going to be like
this one and in this case player B is
going to be like this one what should
player a do well in both cases player a
is getting minus three dollars it
doesn't actually matter play you're a
could do any of them and pull your a at
the end of the day is going to get minus
three dollars and this is a case where a
player a goes first
what if player a goes second second soso
then player B is going first player B is
minimizing and then play your a is
maximizing and we have the same values
here okay
so this is this is player a going second
player a going second tries to maximize
so we'd like to pick these ones player
B's is here player B wants to minimize
so player B is going to be like okay if
you're going second I'd rather I'd
rather show you one because by showing
you one I'm losing less if I show you
two I'm losing even more so and then in
that setting we're gonna get to so
player a is going to get two dollars all
right so that was kind of intuitive if
you have fewer strategies it looks like
if you're going second that should be
better so so going second is no worse
it's the same or better and that
basically can be represented by this
minimax relationship right so so agent a
is trying to maximize so so in this
second case
in the second case we are maximizing
second over our actions of via a and B
and player B is going first so this is
going to be greater than or equal to the
case where player a is going first sorry
no not me that makes sense
so I'm gonna just write these things
that you're learning throughout on the
side of the board maybe up here so what
did we just learn we learned if we have
fewer strategies if we have pure
strategies right going second is better
that sounds intuitive and right okay so
far says it okay so the question that I
want to try to think about right now is
what if we have mixed strategies what's
gonna happen if you have mixed
strategies are we going to get the same
thing look if you have mixed strategies
it's going second better or is it worse
or is it the same so that's a question
in charge at okay so so let's say player
a comes in and play your a says well I'm
gonna reveal my strategy to you what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna flip a coin
depending on what it comes I'm either
show you're going to show you one or I'm
going to show you two that's what I'm
gonna tell you tell you that's what I'm
gonna do so so what would be the value
of the game under that setting so the
value of the game would be maybe all
right it's here so the value of PI a and
PI B PI ay is already this mixed
strategy of 1/2 1/2 right is going to be
equal to PI is this actually alright so
what is that going to be equal to its
going to be PI B times 1 right type so
it's going to be PI
be choosing one times one happy
probability 1/2 agent is also picking
one if it is one one you're gonna get to
write plus I be choosing one PI a with
1/2 choosing one and you're gonna get -
$3 so choosing - you're gonna get -
$3.00 plus PI be choosing 2 times 1/2 PI
a choosing do - you're gonna get $4 plus
PI be choosing 2 times pi a choosing 1
and that's - - so I just like iterated
all the four options that we can get
here under the policy of PI be choosing
one or two and then PI is always just
are following this mixed strategy so
well what is this equal to
that's equal to minus 1 over 2 pi B of 1
plus 1 over 2i b of 2 so that's the
value ok so again the setting is someone
came in agent a came in AJ told me I'm
following this mixed strategy this is
gonna be the thing I'm gonna do what
should I do as an agency what should I
do as an agent Lee
so ok so now it's so quick so you always
have to do one but why why is that well
well if agent a comes and tells me well
this is the thing I want to do I should
try to minimize value of agent a right
so what I'm really trying to do as agent
B is to minimize this right cuz I don't
want agent a to get anything so if I'm
minimizing this and some sense I'm
trying to come up with a policy that
minimizes this is a probability so it's
like a positive number I have like
positive part and negative part here the
way to minimize this is to put as much
weight as possible for this side and as
little as possible for this side so that
tells me that never show too and always
show one does anyone see that so so the
best thing that I can do as agent 2 is
to follow a pure strategy that always
shows 1 and never shows
okay so this was kind of interesting
right like if someone comes in and tells
me this is the thing this is a mixed
strategy I'm gonna follow I'll have a
solution in response to that and that
solution is always going to be a pure
strategy actually so that's I hope cool
all right so so this is actually what's
happening in a more general case I'm
gonna make a lot of generalizations in
this lecture so I show one example and I
generalize it but if you're interested
in details of it we can talk quite at
offline so yeah so the setting is for
any fixed mixed strategy pie a so-so pie
a told me what their mixed strategy is
it's a fixed mixed and mixed strategy
what I should do as agent P's I should
minimize that value I should pick PI B
in a way that minimizes that value and
that can be attained by pure strategy so
the second thing that I've learned here
is if player a plays plays mixed
strategy makes strategy player B has an
optimal pure strategy that's kind of
interesting right okay so so in this
case also we haven't decided what the
policies should be yet right like behave
you have started you still we have still
been talking about the setting we're PI
it like agent a comes in and tells us
what their policy is and we know how to
respond to it it's going to be a pure
strategy so now I want to figure out
what is this this policy like what it
what should be this mixed strategy
actually so so I want to think of it
more generally so so I want to go back
to those two diagrams and actually
modify those two diagrams in a way where
you talk about it a little bit more
generally maybe yeah I'll just modify
these okay so so let's say that okay and
I'm going to think about both of the
settings so let's say it again player a
is deciding to go
first player a is going to follow and
make a mixed strategy so this is all we
know but we don't know what mix strategy
play player a is going to decide to do
to follow a mixed strategy this is
player a player ace maximizing player a
is falling a mixed strategy the way I'm
writing at mixed strategy there's more
generally saying player a is gonna show
one a bit probability P and is going to
show two with probability 1 minus P or
generally like some something value okay
and then after that it's player B Stern
we have just seen that player B the best
thing player B can do this is to do a
pure strategy so player B is either 100%
is going to pick one or a hundred
percent is going to pick turns then like
so the thing is that the strategies are
probabilities right so there are values
from 0 to 1 and then you kind of always
end up with this negative turn that
you're trying to eliminate as negative
as possible and this positive term that
you're trying to get as positive as
possible and that's kind of intuitively
why you end up with a period strategy
and Mercury strategy what I mean is you
always end up like putting as much
possible like 1 like all your
probabilities on the negative term and
nothing on the positive term because
you're trying to minimize this so that's
kind of like intuitively why you are
getting this here's to do so so you
wouldn't get one so silver that's what I
mean so like if you would have never get
like 1/2 + 1 if you get 1/2 and 1/2
that's that's a mixed strategy that's
not a pure strategy and I'm saying you
wouldn't get a mixed strategy because
you would always end up in this setting
that to minimize this you end up pushing
all your probabilities is negative 1 all
right so so all right so let me go back
to this so alright so we have this
setting or a player a goes first play
you're a is following a mixed strategy
with P and 1 minus P player B is going
to follow a period strategy either 1 or
2 I don't know which one right so what's
gonna happen is if you have 1 1 and then
then that is going to give me 2 value 2
all right so it's 2 times P I'm trying
to write a value here by writing it wait
is it 2 times P plus yeah 1 minus P
times 3 right so if we probability 1
minus P this guy's gonna pick 2 but this
guy picks one you're gonna get - three -
three okay and then for this side if
with probability 1 minus P a is gonna
show two if I am gonna show - then I'm
gonna get four so it's 4 times 1 minus P
and we 1200 TP designs are gonna show
one I'm going to show 2 so that is minus
3 all right so what are these equal to
so this is equal to 5 P minus 3 that is
equal to minus 7 P plus 4 right so so
I'm talking about this more general
cases in this more general case player a
comes in clear is playing first and it's
following a mixed strategy but doesn't
know what P they should choose they're
choosing a P and 1 minus P here and then
player B has to follow a pure strategy
that's what we decided
and then under that case we either get
5p minus 3 and minus MP possible what
should player B do here this is player B
and this min node
what should player B do which we should
player B pick one or two it should
player B should pick a thing that
minimizes between these two so player B
is going to take the minimum of 5p minus
3 and minus 7 P plus 4 what should play
your ad what should player a do I'm
thinking minimax right
so when you think about the minimax play
you're a it's maximum maximizing the
value so player is going to maximize the
value that comes up here so player is
going to maximize that and also I'm
saying clear air you needs to decide
what PDR picking so they're gonna pick a
P that maximizes that these computations
yeah so these are the four different
things in my payoff matrix so I'm saying
is with probability P a is going to show
me one right and I'm gonna go down this
other route where B is also choosing one
so one like both of us are showing one
then I'm gonna get two right so I'm
gonna get $2 so that's where the two
dollars comes from times probability P
with probability 1 minus P a is going to
show me - I'm gonna show one that's - $3
times probability 1 minus P so so that's
how and for this particular branch I
know the payoff is going to be 5 P minus
3 that make sense and then for this side
again like with probability 1 minus P is
going to show me - if it is both of them
- I'm gonna get $4 that's why it's 4
times probability 1 minus P your
probability P is going to show me one so
that's why I'll lose $3 that's -3 times
probability P so that's minus 17 so and
then and then the second player what
they're gonna do is they're going to
minimize between these two values
they're gonna pick one or two they're
going they're deciding should I pick one
or should I pick two and the way they
are deciding that is by trying to pick
pick one or two based on which one
minimizes I'm writing it like using this
variable P that's not decided yet and
this variable P is the thing that player
a needs to decide so what what P should
tell you're a decide employer a should
decide repeated maximizes so I'm writing
like literally a minimax relationship
here yeah all right so the interesting
thing here is this 5p minus 3 is some
line right with with positive slope
this is 5p minus and this minus 7 p +
where is another line - 7 P plus 4
it's another line
negative slope what is the minimum of
this where is going to be the minimum of
this happening anymore of these two
lines where they meet each other right
this is going to be a minimum so so the
period I'm going to pick is going to be
actually the P where the value of P
where these two are equal to each other
and that turns out to be at I don't know
what it is 7 over 12 or something
actually I don't know where this what is
this value yeah so it's going to happen
at 7 over 12 and the value of it is
minus 1 over 12 right so ok so let's
recap ok what did I do
so I'm talking about the simultaneous
game but I'm relaxing it and making it
sequential I'm saying a is going to play
first base playing second the thing
that's gonna happen is ace playing first
is deciding to choose a mixed strategy
so he's deciding to say maybe 1/2 1/2
well maybe the a doesn't want to say 1/2
1/2 once to come up with some other
probabilities so the thing is deciding
is should I pick one and with
probability P and should I pick 2 with
probability 1 minus P and what should
that P be so so what is the probability
I should be picking 1 so that's what a
is trying to decide here ok so whatever
a decides with P and 1 minus P ends up
in two different results and based on
them me is trying to minimize that when
B is trying to minimize that B is
minimizing between these two linear
functions these two linear functions
meet at one point that is the points
that this thing is going to be minimized
and that actually corresponds to a
p-value when a nice to maximize this
this is I know but this is requires a
little bit of thinking but any
clarification questions any see a lot of
boss faces so yeah and then yeah the
interesting point is exactly right yeah
so a is 2 by the way of losing so even
in this case where a is trying to come
up with the best mixed strategy he could
do the best mixed strategy a is doing
is shown show 1 with probability 7 over
12 and show 2 with probability 5 over 12
this comes from here even under that
scenario aces is losing minus 1 over 2
ok all right ok so also I haven't solved
a simultaneous game yeah that's right
like I have talked about the setting
where a place first so what if B plays
first so I'm gonna swap this what if he
plays first so a goes second B plays
first I'm gonna modify this one now ok
he goes first
a is going second he is going to start
is going to reveal this strategy his
strategy the strategy that B is going to
reveal is also again I'm gonna with
probability P show you 1 the probability
1 minus P show you show you 2 then a
place is trying to maximize and a has to
play a pure strategy because of that
like the best thing I can do is go into
the appear strategy always going to the
Eider showing 1 or 2 and a is deciding
which one but doesn't know yet and the
values here are going to be exactly the
same thing as third so there are five
point five P minus three minus seven P
plus four
all right so what's happening here so so
in this case a is playing second what a
likes to do is a likes to maximize
between 5p minus 3 and minus 7 P plus 4
that's what a likes to do he is going
second sorry is going first
so then B has to minimize that and pick
it P that minimizes that okay so these
two are exactly the same two lines but
now I'm picking the maximum of them the
maximum of these two lines end up being
exactly the same point as before ends up
being exactly the same P is before and
giving you exactly the same value as
before so so this is also equal to minus
1 over 12 so what this is telling me is
if you're playing a mixed strategy
even if you reveal your best to make
strategy at the beginning it doesn't
matter it actually doesn't matter if
you're going first or second so like in
the more a game and you were playing if
you were playing get make strategy and
you would tell your opponent this is the
thing I'm gonna do and this is a mixed
strategy actually like anything what's
the optimal thing like like you didn't
matter like if they don't know it or not
like you just still get the same value
so again you get 5p minus 3 and minus 7
P plus 4 and then now you're minimizing
or a maximum of these two lines maximum
of these two lines ends up being at the
same point and you pick a P that kind of
maximizes that and you get the same
value so this is called the Von Neumanns
theorem so this whole thing that you
just did over this one example there's a
theorem about it that says for every
simultaneous two player zero-sum game
with a finite number of actions the
order of place doesn't matter so he is
playing second or B's playing first the
values are going to be the same thing if
you're minimizing over a maximum we're
maximizing minimum of that value it's
going to be the same thing okay so this
is kind of the third thing that we just
learned which is one Newman's theorem
which says if I'm writing a modification
of simpler shorter version of it safe
playing makes strategy order of play
doesn't matter and remember if you play
mixed strategy your opponent is going to
play fewer strategy because this is like
this is the first point right if you
play mixed strategy your opponent is
going to follow a pure strategy I don't
want to like you for doing that board or
anything
one of the two answers like look valid
I'll disappear one one like it will be
either one or two and then in that case
the second music so in this case yeah so
so the thing is these two end up being
equal so the way to it doesn't it
doesn't matter because your way for you
to maximize this is going to be the
point where the two end up being equal
so the two branches like if you actually
plug in P equal to 7 over to 12 here
like these two values end up being equal
I'm not an interpretation they're
actually equal and the reason that they
end up being equal is you are trying to
minimize the thing that this guy is
trying to maximize so you're trying to
pick the P that actually makes this
thing equal so no matter what your
opponent's does like you're gonna like
get the best thing that you can do so so
yeah like think of it like this okay so
I'm player a I'm still I still have a
choice my choice is to pick a P I want
to pick a P that I'm not gonna like lose
as much what P should I pick I should
pick a P that makes these choices the
same because if I pick a P that makes
this one higher than this one of course
the second player is going to make me
lose and then go down the routes that's
that's better for the second player so
the best thing that I can do here is
make these two as equal as possible so
then the second player whatever they
choose choose one or two like it's gonna
be the same thing it's going to be those
does that make sense no expectations we
multiplied by P and one was easier
saying like oh so in expectation you're
saying when you're choosing P yeah yeah
so I'm just I'm treating P as a variable
that I'm deciding right like peas the
thing I gotta be deciding so I'm player
a I gotta be citing a P that's not gonna
be too bad for me like let's say I would
pick a P that doesn't make these things
equal let's say I don't know I would
pick your P that makes this guy I don't
know 10 and this makes this guy 5 the
second player is of course going to make
me lose and of course is going to like
pick the thing that's going to be the
worst thing for me so the best thing I
can do is I can like make both of them I
don't know 7 so it's not gonna be as bad
so so that's kind of the idea all right
so we move forward because there's so
much things happening all right so it's
okay so the kind of key idea here is
revealing your
optimal make strategy does not hurt you
which is kind of a cool idea the proof
of that is interesting if you're
interested in look at the notes you can
use linear programming here the reason
kind of the intuition behind it is if
you're playing mixed strategy the next
person it has to play pure strategy and
you have n possible options for that
keyword strategy so that creates n
constraints that you're putting in for
your optimization you end up with a
single optimization with n constraints
and then you can use like linear
programming duality to actually solve it
so you could compute this using linear
programming and that's kind of the one
LS here so so let's summarize what we
have talked about so far so so we have
talked about these simultaneous games
and and we've talked about the setting
where we have pure strategies and we saw
that if you have pure strategies going
second is better right going second is
better if you're just telling you like
what's the pure strategy you're using
right so that was none of the first
point couple and then if you're using
mixed strategies it turns out it doesn't
matter if you're going first or a second
you're telling them what you're mixed
best mixed strategy is and they're going
to respond based on that so and that's
the Von Neumanns minimax there all right
so next ten minutes I want to spend a
little bit of time talking about non
zero sum games so so far we have talked
about zero-sum games where it's either
minimax I get some reward you get the
negative of that or vice versa there are
also these other things called
collaborative games where we were just
supposed to maximizing something so we
both get like money out of it and that's
kind of like a single optimization it's
a single maximization you can think of
it as playing search in real life you're
kind of somewhere in between that and I
want to motivate that by an example so I
want to be that but by this idea of
prisoner's dilemma how many of you have
heard of prisoner's dilemma ok good ok
so the idea of prisoner's dilemma is you
have a prosecutor who asks a and B
individually if they will testify
against each other or not ok if both of
them testified and both of them are
sentenced to five years in jail
if both of them refused and both of them
are sentenced to one year in jail if one
testifies then he or she gets out for
free and and then the other one gets ten
years sentence
play with your partner real quick
okay so let's look at the payoff matrix
so I think you kind of have an idea of
how the game works so so you have two
players a or B each one of you have an
option you can either testify or you can
refuse to testify so you can you can
testify and you can refuse to testify
and I'm going to create this payoff
matrix this payoff matrix is going to
have two entries now in each one of
these in these cells and then why is
that because we have a non zero sum game
before our payoff matrix only had one
entry because this was for player a
player B would just get negative of that
but now for your a and B are getting
different values so if both of us
testify then both of us get five years
jail right so hey gets five years in
jail he gets five years right if both of
us refuse and gets one year jail he gets
one year jail one year one year gee and
then if it is a setting or one of us
testifies the other one refuses one of
us gets Nero the other one gets ten
years jail so if I refuse to testify
then I get ten years and then B gets
zero and then in this case a gets 0 and
B gets ten yeah so the payoff matrix is
now going to be for every player we are
gonna have a payoff matrix so so now we
have this this v value function which is
a function of a player for policy a and
policy B will be the utility for one
particular player because you might be
looking the idea from perspective of
different players okay so the one known
as minimax theorem it doesn't really
apply here because we don't have the
zero sum game but you actually get
something a little bit weaker and that's
the idea of Nash equilibrium so a Nash
equilibrium is set of policies PI star a
and PI star B so that no player has an
incentive to change their strategy so
what does that mean so what that means
is if you look at the value function
from perspective employer a value phone
from perspective player a at the Nash
equilibrium at PI star a and PI star B
is going to be greater than or equal to
value of any other policy PI a if you
fix pipe and at the same time the same
thing is true for value of me so for
agent p value of B Atma and Nash
equilibrium is going to be greater than
or equal to a value of B at any other PI
B if if PI a fixes their Falls okay so
what does that mean in this setting do
we have a Nash equilibrium here so let's
say I start from here I start from a
equal to minus 10 B equal to 0 can I get
this better and I make this better I did
I flip them I only flipped right 0 minus
n minus 10 0 okay so let's say I start
from here can I get can I get this
better and I make this better I start
from this cell a gets 0 years of jail
that's pretty good he gets 10 years of
ill that's not that great so he has an
incentive to change that right like he
has an incentive to actually move in
this direction right so B has an
incentive to get 5 years jail instead of
10 years similar thing here what if you
start here a has 1 year jail B has 1
year jail they have an incentive to
change this now and get 0 years jail he
has an incentive to change this and get
0 and we end up with this cell where
like you don't have any incentive to
change our strategy so we have one Nash
equilibrium here and that one Nash
equilibrium here is both of us are
testifying and both of us are getting 5
years jail it's kind of interesting
because there is like a socially better
choice to have here I like both of us
like if both of us were with your fuse
like you would each had one year jail
but that's not gonna be Nash equilibria
all right so there's a theorem which is
Ash's existence theorem which basically
says if any finite player game with
finite number of actions if you have any
finite for your game we find out number
of actions then there exists at least
one
Shaku Libyan and then this is usually
one mixed strategy Nash equilibria on
mixed strategy Nash equilibrium in this
case it's actually a pure strategy Nash
equilibria but but in general there's at
least one Nash equilibrium if you have
game this one okay all right
so so let's look at a few other examples
two-finger Maura what would be a Nash
equilibrium for that so we just actually
solved the dad's using the minimax
oneness minimax theorem right so so it
would be if you're playing it makes
strategy of seven over 12 and 5 over 12
you might you might kind of modify your
two finger Mora game and make it
collaborative so in a collaborative
setting and what that means is we both
get two dollars or we both get four
dollars or we both lose three dollars so
so a collaborative two finger morai game
it's not a zero-sum game anymore and and
you have two Nash equilibria so you
would have a setting where a and B both
of them play one and the values two or a
and B both of them play two values 4 and
then prisoner's dilemma it's the case
where both of them passive life we just
just saw that on the world alright okay
so the summary so far is we've talked
about simultaneous zero-sum games we
talked about this one knowing mins
minimax theorem which has like multiple
minimax strategies and the single game
value like we had a single game value
because it was zero-sum but in the case
of non zero sum games we would have
something that's slightly weaker that's
Nash's existence theorem we would still
have multiple Nash equilibria we could
have multiple Nash equilibria but we
have multiple we also have multiple game
values from depending on whose
perspective you're looking at so this
kind of was just a brief like short
introduction to game theory and econ
there is a huge literature around
different types of games in game theory
and economics if you're interested in
that take classes and yeah there are
other types of games too like security
games or resource allocation games that
have
some characteristics that are similar to
things you have talked about you're
interested in any of them maybe you can
take a look at them would be useful for
projects and with that I'll see you guys
next time